there's growing outrage after a bill to
help around three and a half million
veterans exposed to toxic military burn
pits was blocked in the senate one of
the biggest champions of the measure
comedian jon stewart was visibly upset
when 41 republican senators voted to
stall the bill he called it a disgrace
this is a story we've been following
extensively here at cbs morning's senior
investigative correspondent katherine
herrich has the reaction
they haven't met a veteran they won't
screw over
what the f
are we
comedian and veterans advocate jon
stewart voiced the deep personal anger
and frustration felt by so many thursday
on capitol hill as the effort to advance
bipartisan burn pit legislation failed
they're not on senate time they're on
human time cancer time the bill would
cost an estimated 180 billion dollars
over the first four years expanding
health care and disability coverage
benefits for nearly two dozen illnesses
linked to toxic smoke including
respiratory problems and rare cancers it
was constantly being fed a stream of
garbage on one side and jet fuel on the
other army veteran mark jackson was
exposed to military burn pits in
afghanistan the ash from the burn pit
would fall kind of like snow
onto the tents of course onto your skin
and into your eyes as part of an ongoing
cbs morning's investigation jackson
shared his long list of medical issues
including anemia osteoporosis and
thyroid disorder i don't care if it
costs twice as much as the wars that we
fought because they need to budget for
the peace just like they budget for the
war in june the bill had bipartisan
support the motion is not agreed to but
by wednesday 25 senate republicans
changed their vote to no raising
concerns over how the money was budgeted
arguing it could be spent on programs
unrelated to veterans in the future
yesterday democrats pushed back they
voted against the men and women who
fight for this country that want to
return back to civilian life and have a
normal life and not only those folks but
their families stewards said there was
no excuse for washington's delay their
constituents are dying
and they're going to get it done recess
you know tell their cancer to take a
recess
and veterans advocates are calling on
congress not to leave washington until
the legislation passes the next
opportunity is monday with another
procedural vote in the meantime veteran
mark jackson told cbs news there are a
lot of good intentions but more
disappointment after years of suffering
and their service scale
jon stewart pulling no punches there
thank you very much catherine